سعودي ايراني المشترك الاتفاق على استئناف
الرحلات الجويه والترتيب لفتح الممثليات
الدبلوماسيه
مستوطنون يقتحمون المسجد الاقصى صباح
اليوم والشرطه الاسرائيليه تفرض قيودا على
دخول الفلسطينيين
تاجير التوقيع على اتفاق السياسي النهائي
في السودان والحريه والتغيير تدعو للتظاهر
اليوم
[موسيقى]
في هذه النشره المفصله من العربيه ونبداها
من بكين حيث التقى وزير خارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان نظيره الايراني حسين
امير عبد الهيان في العاصمه الصينيه صباح
اليوم وذلك لتفعيل مضمون اتفاق استئناف
العلاقات بين الرياض وطهران المعلن عنه
الشهر الماضي وزير الخارجيه السعودي
وايراني اتفقا في ختام اللقاء على القيام
بكل ما يلزم لتحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه
وعقبا اللقاء بين وزيري الخارجيه وقاعه
السعوديه وايران بيانا مشتركا جاء فيه انه
تم الاتفاقه على بدء ترتيبات اعاده فتح
السفرتين والقن وكذلك استئناف الرحلات
الجويه وتسهيل مرحله تاشيرات للمواطنين
كما تم الاتفاق على استئناف تبادل زياره
المسؤولين وزير خارجيه السعودي دعا في هذا
السياق دعا نظيره الايراني لعقد لقاء
ثنائي في الرياض
في تطورات الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
يتواصل التوتر في الحرم القدسي حيث اقتحمت
مجموعه من المستوطنين الاسرائيليين صباح
اليوم المسجد الاقصى وسط حمايه مشدده من
القوات الاسرائيليه التي فرضت قيودا فجر
اليوم على دخول المصلين الى الحرم القدسي
لاداء صلاه الفجر في وقت تواصلت ايضا
المواجهات في ازقه البد القديمه في القدس
بين الشبين الفلسطينيين والشرطه يحدث هذا
في وقت ينتظر ان يعقد مجلس الامن جاسه
انطاليا اليوم الخميس لبحث اقتحامات
الاسرائيليه للمسجد الاقصى وذلك بطلب مصري
اردني الناطق الرسمي باسم الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه نبيل قال انما تقوم به اسرائيل
من اقتحام للمسجد الاقصى المبارك
والاعتداء على المصلين يشكل صفعه للجهود
الامريكيه التي حاولت خلال الفتى الماضيه
ايجاد حاله من الهدوء والاستقرار في شهر
رمضان المبارك
وعلى حدود غزه اعلن متحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه تم رصد اطلاق صاروخين
بقطاع غزه باتجاه اسرائيل مساء الاربعاء
مشيرا الى ان احدهما سقط داخل القطاع
والاخر في منطقه السياج الحدودي واضاف ان
ذلك ادى الى تفعيل نظام الانذار من
الصواريخ هذا هو افادت وسائل اعلام
فلسطينيه بسماع دوري انفجارات في بلدات
قريبه من بئر السابع في النقب الغربي
وكذلك سماع انطلاق صفاره الانذار
وفي احدث ردود الفعل على عمليه اقتحام
المسجد الاقصى حذر الاردن من استماره
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على المصلين
والمعتكفين في المسجد ومحاولات تغيير
الوضع التاريخي والقانوني القائم وحملت
الخارجيه الاردنيه اسرائيل مسؤوليه
التبعات الخطيره لاستمرار العنف داعيه
المجتمع الدولي لتحمل مسؤولياته ووقف هذه
الاعتداءات الخارجيه الروسيه دعت بدورها
في بيان الى ضروره اتخاذ اجراءات عاجله
لتهدئه الوضع في اقرب وقت ممكن وتهيئه
الظروف اللازمه لبدء عمليه سياسيه مستدامه
تهدف الى تسويه عادله للقضيه الفلسطينيه
على اساس قرارات الامم المتحده ومجلس
الامن ذات الصله
هكذا بدا المشهد في المصلى القبلي وساحات
المسجد الاقصى لساعات حيث اقتحمت القوات
الاسرائيليه المكان واعتدت على المعتكفين
المصلى القبلي تحول الى ساحه معركه لليوم
الثاني على التوالي في اعناف اقتحامات
واعتداءات منذ العام 2000
لم يعتاد عليها بهذه الوحشيه ولكن هناك
رسائل واضحه بانهم سيستخدمون العمق المفرط
وهذه احد الاساليب للسيطره من خلال تخويف
ودوائر عام المعتدين بعد اخلاء الاقصى من
الفلسطينيين امتدت المواجهات الى ازقه
البلده القديمه في القدس الشرقيه المحتله
كما انتقل التصعيد الى مدن داخل الخط
الاخضر وفي الضفه الغربيه وعلى جبهه قطاع
غزه ايضا
[موسيقى]
اهلا احمد فعليا بعد ليله صعبه جدا شاهدها
الفلسطينيين والمقدسيين في المسجد الاقصى
وباحاته اليوم كان هناك ايضا فجر اليوم
يعني منع الشرطه الاسرائيليه اعداد كبيره
من الشبان من الدخول واداه صلاه الفجر في
المسجد الاقصى لذلك اعداد كبيره ايضا من
الشبان والفلسطينيين ادوا صلاه الفجر خارج
اسوار المسجد الاقصى فيما يعني انتشرت
ايضا اعداد كبيره من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
وحواجز يعني على ابواب المسجد الاقصى
جميعها كان هناك ايضا صباح اليوم اربع
مجموعات من قبل المستوطنين قاموا باقتحام
ساحات المسجد الاقصى بحمايه مشدده من قبل
القوات الاسرائيليه ايضا نحن نتحدث عن
اقتحامات كبيره لاعداد كبيره من
المستوطنين بحمايه كبيره من قبل الشرطه
الاسرائيليه وقامت ايضا حاولت اخلاء او
اخراج اعداد ايضا من الشبان فسمحت فجر
اليوم فقط
كبار السن منهم اكبر من اربعين عاما
الدخول والصلاه في المسجد الاقصى نحن
نتحدث عن اعتداءات كبيره حتى يعني الاشخاص
المصابين الذين اصيبوا ليله امس فعليا في
المواجهات كانت الشبان تتحدث ان الشرطه
الاسرائيليه تتعمد اصابه الشبان في الاعين
في الصدر في الراس وفي الجزء العلوي
للشباب وذلك للحاق اكبر قدر ممكن من الضرر
اضافه لذلك يعني القوات الاسرائيليه تحاول
ابعاد اعداد كبيره من الشبان عن المسجد
الاقصى هناك اكثر من 400 او 500 شاب تم
نفهم اي هم ممنوع ان يقتربوا على البلده
القديمه او حتى على المسجد الاقصى لمده
اسبوع وممكن القوات الاسرائيليه
تمدد هذه المده هناك حديث ايضا عن مواجهات
في ازقه بدل القديمه في القدس لان هل ما
زالت هذه المواجهات مستمره بانها توقفت
بين شبين الفلسطينيين وبين ايضا من القوات
الاسرائيليه
ليله امس كان هناك حتى فجر اليوم عده
اشتباكات في حارات ويعني مناطق مختلفه في
البلده القديمه لكن الان دعنا نشير بان
هناك يعني هدوء حذر حسب ما يتم وصفه ولكن
نتحدث ايضا عن ربما سوف يكون غدا جمعه غضب
بدا الشبان يتحدثون عن جمعه غضب في الضفه
الغربيه او حتى في مدن وقرى داخل الخط
الاخضر شاهدنا ايضا مواجهات عنيفه في
الباقه في باقه الغربيه وايضا ام الفحم
القرى الفلسطينيه المتواجده في اراضي 48
اي نحن نتحدث عن ان الساحه الفلسطينيه في
جميع المناطق الان تتحد ضد اعتداءات
الاسرائيليه على المسجد الاقصى فربما سوف
نشهد غدا هناك مواجهات عنيفه في جمعه
الغضب حسب ما يصفها الشبان الفلسطينيين
نعم سنكون معك في متابعه دائمه
العربيه لان كل تحياتي لنا
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
اتهامات جديده لترامب بمحاوله مصادره الات
التصويت في انتخابات 2020
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد التقى وزير
الدفاع السعوديه الامير خالد بن سلمان
رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسي اليمني الدكتور
رشاد العليمي واعضاء المجلس وقال وزير
الدفاع السعوديه عبر حسابه على تويتر انه
خلال اللقاء تم استعراض عمق العلاقات
الاخويه التي تجمع البلدين الشقيقين
نؤكدان استماره دعم المملكه المتواصل
اليمن ولمجلس القياده الرئاسي اليمني في
كافه المجالات مما يسهم في الوصول الى حل
سياسي شامل ينهي الازمه اليمنيه
في السودان مشاهدينا اكد رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان العزم على
استكمال العمليه السياسيه في البلاد مشيرا
الى ان تاجيل توقيع الاتفاق السياسي يهدف
الى وضع الاطر المتينه للمحافظه على
الثوره ولفت البرهان الى ان جميع الاطراف
تعمل الان لاكمال النقاش بشان القضايا
المتبقيه
هذا ونشرت قوى الحريه والتغيير في السودان
قبل ذلك بيانا اعلنت فيه تاجيل توقيع
الاتفاق السياسي الذي كان مقررا اليوم
لعدم استكمال الجوانب الخاصه بالاصلاح
الامني والعسكري ودعت السودانيين للمشاركه
الفاعل في مواكب السادس من ابريل في
العاصمه
على ضروره التمسك بالسلميه كما طالبت قوى
الحريه والتغيير الاجهزه الامنيه
والعسكريه بحمايه المواكب الشعبيه محذره
من اي تعامل عنيف تجاه المشاركين
مصادر عسكريه سودانيه مطلع نفت وجود اي
توتر عسكري في الخرطوم واكدت ان القوات
المسلحه كعهدها ووفق مؤسساتها ونظم عملها
تبسط سيطرتها على مواطن الامن في السودان
كافه ولا ترتيبات خاصه لديها للتصدي لاي
اخطار ربما تنشا على امن العاصمه او
البلاد
في ملف الحرب الاوكراني اعلن قائد القوات
الاوكرانيه المشتركه سيرغناييف ان منظومه
الدفاع الجوي الامريكيه افنجرز دخلت
الخدمه في الجيش الاوكراني
ونشرناف مقطع فيديو يظهر بعض القطع من هذا
النظام الدفاعي واضحا ان عناصر الجيش
الاوكراني العاملين على المنظومه تدربوا
على استخدامها في المانيا واكد قائد
القوات الاوكرانيه المشتركه ان المنظومه
الامريكي افنجر ستساهم في التعزيز حمايه
المجال الجوي لمنطقه العمليات الشماليه
باستخدام الاسلحه التي قدمتها الدول
الاعضاء في حلف الناتو
كما اقرها الرئيس الاوكراني بامكانيه
الانسحاب بمدينه باخم متقائلا ان الاهم هو
عدم خساره الجيش ولا يجب فقدان افراد بسبب
الحصار لكنه ايضا اضاف ان شحنه الذخيره من
حلفاء اوكرانيا ستعزز الدفاعات العسكريه
وتمكن الجيش من المحاربه بشكل اسرع ليس في
بخموت فحسب بل في جميع الاراضي الاوكرانيه
هذا وكشف الرئيس الاوكراني عن فحوى
محادثاته مع نظيره البولندي اندريدودا
موضحا انها تناولت الحزمه الدفاعيه
الجديده وايضا قضيه المزارعين بين البلدين
ناقشنا قضيه المزارعين في بولندا
واوكرانيا وتم التوصل الى حل اعتقد انه في
الايام والاسابيع المقبله سنحل جميع
المشكلات اخيرا لانه لا يمكن ان تكون هناك
صعوبات بين الشركاء المقربين والاصدقاء
الحقيقيين
في اليوم الثاني لزيارته الى الصين التقى
الرئيس الفرنسي
رئيس البرلمان الصيني الرئيس الفرنسي كان
دعا امس لدوري صيني لانهاء حرب اوكرانيا
محذرا الاوروبيين من مخاطر الابتعاد عن
بكين وبحسب بيان اليزي ستركز زيارته على
ثلاثه محاور هي القضايا الاستراتيجيه
والازمه الدوليه والتعاون في مواجهه
تحديات العالميه الكبرى وكذلك العلاقات
الاقتصاديه
تفرقهما السياسه لكن تجمعهما المصالح
الاقتصاديه الاتحاد الاوروبي والصين
يحاولان ايجاد طريق سالكه للشراكه
المستقبليه في غابه دوليه تحكمها الصراعات
والتطاحنات العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين بيكين
وبروكسل وثيقه رغم نمو تيار داخل الاتحاد
يدعو الى تقليل التعامل معها فقبل حوالي
سنتين تمكنت الصين من تبوء مكانه الشريك
التجاري العالمي الاول للمنطقه الاوروبيه
خلفا للولايات المتحده
حاملا ملفات السياسه والاقتصاد حل الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون بالصين الى جانب
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسولا فوندير
لاين التي استبقت رحلتها بخطاب اكدت فيه
ان على اوروبا اللجوء الى ادوات دفاعيه
جديده في علاقتها مع التنين الاسيوي وما
تقصده هو وقف تصدير التكنولوجيا الحساسه
الى الصين وتقليل الاعتماد على الاستيراد
منها ما اعتبره السفير الصيني لدى بروكسل
انتهاكا لقواعد التجاره الدوليه
الرئيس الفرنسي ومن خلال هذه الزياره يسعى
للاستمرار بالدفع باتجاه ولوج افضل الى
السوق الصينيه كما انه لا ينسى السياسه
والحرب في اوكرانيا فحسب ماكرون بكين
يمكنها ان تؤثر في صنع السلام بسبب قربها
من موسكو
لقد اثرت الحرب التي قادتها روسيا في
اوكرانيا بشكل عميق على النظام الدولي
الذي عرفناه منذ عام 19
واربعين هذه الحرب انتهكت العديد من مبادئ
ميثاق الامم المتحده والتي يجب علينا
الدفاع عنها بحزم لذا يمكن للصين على وجه
التحديد بسبب علاقاتها الوثيقه مع روسيا
ان تلعب دورا رئيسيا زياره ماكرون
فيه الصراع بين الولايات المتحده والصين
سواء في شان ما تراه واشنطن مسانده صينيه
لروسيا في حرب اوكرانيا او الخلاف بشان
تايوان
بواشنطن تصاعد اجراءاتها الاقتصاديه
والتجاريه اتجاه بيكن وتضغط على حلفائها
الاوروبيين للحد من علاقاتهم التجاريه
والاقتصاديه مع الصين لكن منطق المصالح
يجعل هذه العلاقه اقتصاديه اولا واخيرا
بلال الوجداني العربيه
شددت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه على ان قضيه
تايوان تعتبر الخط الاحمر الاول الذي لا
تستطيع الولايات المتحده تجاوزه في
العلاقات مع الصين وقالت الوزاره في بيان
لها ان قضيه تايوان تدخل في نطاق المصالح
الرئيسيه للصين وان استقلالها يتعارض مع
السلام والاستقرار بين ضفتين مضيق تايوان
ودعت الخارجيه الصينيه الولايات المتحده
الى التقيد الصارم بمبدا الصين الواحده
وزاره الدفاع الصينيه بدورها شجبت لقاء
رئيس تيتايوان في كاليفورنيا مع رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي كيفن وقالت الوزاره في
بيان ان الصين تعارض بشده جميع اشكالها
التفاعل الرسمي واي زياره يقوم بها زعيم
تايواني للولايات المتحده تحت اي مسمن او
ذريعه واضافت الوزاره ان الجيش الصيني
سيبقى في حال تاهب قصوى وانه سيحمي بحزم
سياده الصين وسلامه اراضيها وكذلك السلامه
والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان
في هذه الاثناء اعلن التايوان انها رفضت
ثلاثه سفن حربيه ومروحيه صينيه مضاده
غواصات بالقرب من الجزيره وقال وزير
الدفاع التايواني سيوكيوتينغ ان حامله
الطائرات الصينيه ومجموعتها المقاتله تجري
تدريبات في تلك المنطقه لكن في وقت حساس
بحسب تعبيره
متابعه لقضيه محاكمه ترامب نقلت قناه سي
ان ان عن مسؤولين بمجلس الامن القومي خلال
شهادتهم لدى هيئه المحلفين بنيويورك قولهم
انهم ابلغوا ترامب عندما كان رئيسا انه لا
يستطيع حجز اله التصويت وذلك بعد ان اشتكى
من التزوير واتهم الديمقراطيين نتائج
انتخابات 2020 قناه سي ان ان اشارت ايضا
الى ان ترامب حاول قلب خسارته الى فوز من
خلال سعيه لمصادره الات التصويت
الالكتروني انذاك ما يعيد قضيه انتخابات
2020 الى الواجهه من جديد
هذا وقال محامي رئيس الامريكي السابق ان
قال انما يحصل بخصوص القضايا الموجهه
لموكله هي عمليه تسليح للنظام القانوني
وهي سابقه في تاريخ السياسه الامريكيه
بعد الاطلاع على لائحه الاتهام ومعرفه ما
هو القانون بخصوص الحملات الانتخابيه
الفيدراليه لا اعتقد اننا نقترب من هيئه
المحلفين اذا وصلنا الى هيئه المحلفين
اعتقدوا ان اي شخص سواء كان على اليمين او
معرضا سياسيا للترامب او لصالحه سيرى
الحقيقه انه تسليح نظام القانوني
كان يصرف بحقيقه تمت كتابتها في الديل من
اكبر منشور على الانترنت في العالم حيث
كشفوا حقيقه ان بعض افراد عائله القاضي
عملوا مع نائبه الرئيس
الحاليس هذه حقيقه واقعيه وليست هجوما على
القاضي او عائلته تعليقات الرئيس ترامب لم
على العنف اطلاقا
قال صحيفه واشنطن نائب رئيس الامريكي
السابق سيمتثل لامر الشهاده حول احداث
الكابيتول واضافت الصحيفه
كبرى للشهاده حول محادثاتهم مع رئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب قبل احداث الكابيتول
التي وقعت يوم السادس من يناير من عام
امر زعيم طالبانه هبه الله اخوان زاهد
بنقل المتحدثين رسميين باسم الحركه ومسؤول
الاعلام من كابول الى قندهار مراقبون يرون
ان هذه القرارات تمثل خطوات جديده في
احكام سيطره زعيم الحركه على الحكومه
من كابول الى قندهار زعيم حركه طالبان
يغير معادله المكان ليصبح الزمان في قبضته
للسيطره اكثر هبه الله اخ زاده يحول
المتحدثين الرسميين باسم الحركه ومسؤوليه
الاعلام من العاصمه الى قندهار في جنوب
البلاد وبالاخص المتحدث الرسمي ذبيح الله
مجاهد وبها عين رئيس مركز المعلومات
والاعلام الوطني انعم الله ثمن غالي رئيسا
للثقافه والاعلام خطوات اخون زاده تهدف
الى احكام سيطرته على الحكومه ووسائل
الاعلام واعلان مواقفه بشكل اسهل وفق
مراقبين للشان الافغاني
ياتي هذا بعد ان اكدت معلومات وجود
انشقاقات داخل الحركه
واستمتعا بقياده بارزه من احاديه اتخاذ
القرارات في اداره البلاد ابرزها وزير
الداخليه سراج الدين حقاني ما دفعه الى
السعي لتشكيل ما يشبه مجلس شورى للحكم
هكذا استطاع استماله وزير الدفاع محمد
يعقوب ابن مؤسس الحركه الملا عمر واقناعه
بالتشاور مع القاده من اجل العمل بشكل جدي
على تشكيل المجلس
في الاثناء مسؤولون بالامم المتحده قالوا
ان سلطات طالبان في شرق افغانستان منعت
الموظفات الافغانيات في المنظمه من العمل
وبالرغم من وعود في البدايه بحكم اكثر
اعتدالا من السابق فرض الطالبان اجراءات
صارمه منذ استيلائها على السلطه ليبقى
مصير الافغان رهينا بقرارات حركه تستمد
سلطتها من قوه السلاح فقط بلال الوجداني
العربيه
وفي نهايه نرسم مشاهدينا نذكر بابراز
العناوين
بيان سعودي الايراني مشترك على استئناف
الرحلات الجويه والترتيب لفتح الممثليات
الدبلوماسيه
مستوطنون يقتحمون المسجد الاقصى صباح
اليوم والشرطه الاسرائيليه تفرض قيودا على
دخول الفلسطينيين
تاجيل التوقيع على اتفاق السياسي النهائي
في السودان والحريه والتغيير تدعو للتظاهر
اليوم
نهايه هذه المشاهدين كونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]